das herz auf der zunge zu tragen ist für
politisch verantwortliche eher nicht zu
empfehlen doch wie reagieren wenn ein
tyrann ein nachbarland in schutt und
asche legt dazu schweigen joe biden hat
sich fürs reden entschieden und putin so
war es zu verstehen zum teufel gewünscht
prompt kamen die reaktionen verhalten
ebenso wie heftige beiden provokation
wie umgehen mit putin jetzt in der
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio ist elend kohl
französische journalisten innen sie
berichten aus berlin unter anderem für
die wochenzeitung journal du dimanche
also sonntagszeitung und sie haben einen
podcast mit dem eingängigen titel
almanya prix merkel also deutschland
nach angela merkel und ebenfalls hier im
studio ist eric kirschbaum us
amerikanischer journalist und sie
schreiben unter anderem für die los
angeles times
zugeschaltet aus warschau ist unsere
polnische kollegin magdalena coach sie
sind freie journalistinnen und arbeiten
in erster linie für die deutsche welle
aus der polnischen hauptstadt und
schließlich professor wilfried bergmann
rechtswissenschaftler sie sind einer der
drei stellvertretenden vorsitzenden des
deutsch russischen forums und verwalten
gemeinsam mit den beiden anderen im
moment den vorsitz als nachfolger des
zurückgetretenen matthias platzeck herr
köster um gottes willen dieser mann
haben nicht an der macht bleiben das war
das los joe biden am samstag vor dem
warschauer schloss gesagt hat war das
ein aufruf zum sturz putins wie das
viele verstanden haben nein ich glaube
bei denen die industrie schnitt das ganz
klar gemacht ihr wirken regime change
das war mir einer mode finale potter
hinzugefügt einfach die emotionen bis
hin zu sammen zu fassen und die rede ist
eine gruppe vielleicht ein bisschen
kontrovers aufgenommen aber den usa kam
das sehr positiver
stark stärke gezeigt führung gezeigt und
das wir wollten die amerikaner und ein
paar wird über die russische panzer
nicht aufhalten aber wenn das die
alliierten zusammenhalten soll das ist
vielleicht eine gute sache von kohl
schlechter und glücksversprechen
verbrecher hat beiden putin auch genannt
micron hat ja diese wortwahl abgelehnt
weil frankreich sich da ein
diplomatisches hintertürchen offen
halten ja definitiv also sie haben
gesagt ein paar wörter werden die panzer
nicht anhalten ich glaube schon dass
microsoft das ein paar anrufe diese
panzer anhalt wir werden
vergehen also er hat heute nachmittag
nochmal mit werden putin telefoniert
in absprache mit den alliierten also die
vereinigten staaten groß beteiligen
italien deutschland und frankreich also
diese 55 format das ist definitiv den
weg dass frankreich welt seit anfang
dieser diese diese krieg und jetzt
diesen krieg dieses krieges mal sehen
wie lange man noch mit guten reden kann
die wortwahl wir sind immer noch bei der
wortwahl gegenüber putin die wortwahl
kann ja für die polen gar nicht deutlich
genug sein
naja diese diamanten der sendung zitiert
haben er wurde tatsächlich hier nicht
oder deren interpretation in den
mittelpunkt gerückt es liegt vielleicht
einerseits dass ich viel weniger wichtig
halte daran dass die übersetzung zum
beispiel im fernsehen das nicht so
wieder gehabt es sank wiederum an die
akzentuierung aber was viel wichtiger
ist hier herrsche die auffassung vor
dass eine harte sprache die richtige
antwort auf putins russland ist insofern
wurde dieser satz gar nicht so negativ
konnotiert und ist auch nicht negativ
aufgefallen während im westen ja gesagt
man solle für den brückenbau nämlich in
die enge treiben ist eben nicht die
auffassung dass eine harte narration
gebe ich die antwort ist merkt man das
was da beiden gesagt hat war das eine
aufforderung an die russische macht
elite sich spätestens nach dem ukraine
krieg sich putins zu entledigen
ich glaube schon dass das zumindest so
als unterton angekommen ist ich habe
zweifel ob beiden das wirklich so
gemeint hat denn er wird sich natürlich
völlig darüber im klaren sein dass er
und die amerikanische bevölkerung nicht
entscheidet wer in russland gewählt wird
und wer macht ausübt von daher halte ich
von derartigen wortspielen eigentlich
gar nichts denn sie führen eigentlich
dazu dass es gesprächsatmosphäre mit
personen mit denen man muss man kann
sich sie ja nicht aussuchen herr putin
kann sich auch nicht an beiden aussuchen
gesprächsatmosphäre einfach kaputt macht
und von daher sind derartige verbale
akte
kontraproduktiv wenn man letztlich zu
einem ergebnis kommen will das im
positive konnotation hat und ich glaube
daran ist muss letztlich auch den
amerikanern gelegen seien gut in die
wanne gesprächsatmosphäre mit putin noch
möglich ist werden wir noch besprechen
in der sendung und noch ansprechen wenn
russland den krieg verlieren sollte also
jedenfalls nicht die wesentliche
kriegsziele erreichte in der ukraine
dann ist das schicksal putins
möglicherweise gezielt das weiß man
nicht aber was ist eigentlich wenn
russland seine kriegsziele erreicht also
den krieg gewinnt ausgeschlossen ist das
nicht das glaube ich nicht ich glaube
cryan verteidigt seine eigene tor wo die
wilden kerle und kämpfen und kämpfen und
die werden nicht gewinnen die wissen
jetzt wie afghanistan wie wir da haben
die usa gegen die briten vor zwei jahren
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass wir
in diesem krieg gewinnt glauben sie denn
dass das hat er ja vielleicht gibt es
ein
es kann ja sein dass gar keine von
beiden gewinnt das ist doch die viel
wahrscheinlichere situation zumindestens
für einen längeren zeitraum
und so lange muss man miteinander
auskommen und so lange wäre es
vielleicht auch ganz gut wenn die
zivilbevölkerung in der ukraine nicht
unter kampfhandlungen leidet das muss
man doch eigentlich im auge haben
was wie sie frankreich das oder wie
sieht man auf den ukrainer konflikt auf
den ausgang des ukraine konfliktes also
ich glaube momentan ist man noch nicht
soweit also es gibt einen krieg leute
sterben tagtäglich es gibt bombardierung
jeden tag es gibt leute die in mariupol
verhungern und so weit ist man auch
nicht also man muss erst mal sprechen
über die situation die aktuelle
situation und weil man braucht erstmal
einen waffenstillstand und dann müssen
wir mal gucken wer hat da sich geben
gewonnen gibt es tatsächlich 0 gewinner
in dieser situation und was suchen wir
alle zusammen aber erstmal müssen wir
dieses krieg irgendwie beenden und
beobachten ja manche autokratien oder
diktaturen ganz aufmerksam diesen
konflikte china der iran zum beispiel
nordkorea wenn es dafür putin ja
doch noch irgendeinen erfolg zu
vermelden gibt wenn er sich doch mit
etwas behaupten kann kassieren ermuntern
diese drei länder die jetzt genannt habe
ihre eigenen regionalen konflikte
vielleicht zu schüren natürlich so dass
der große fehler seit 20 14 folgen in
deutschland dass man punkten belohnt hat
für den crm anerkennung das nord stream
zwei genehmigt wurde von deutschland
20.15 solche wohnungen für dieses
benehmen mutig auch diktaturen in der
welt und ich habe deutschland muss sich
wirklich an die nase fassen und gucken
was die entscheidung die letzte 56 10
jahren wollen und meinen deutschland mag
begangen hat bewertung ganz gut aber ich
finde diese ukraine krise hat
deutschland viel zu wenig über seine
eigene fehler gemacht die letzten sechs
jahren und es tut mir leid 0 2 war bis
dezember von dieser regierung
unterstützt aus wirtschaftliches projekt
und das war von anfang an ein projekt um
ukrainer zu schwächen ganz europa hat
das gesehen 0 die deutschen nicht die
ganze deutsche politische lied das ich
wirklich an die nase ein bisschen fassen
und seine eigene
farbe haben hier diese diktatur booten
zu ermutigen frage wo ich nehme mal an
dass in polen es ist immer gut sich
immer gut sich an die nase zu fassen
aber vielleicht fängt man bei der
eigenen am besten an
das erleichtert die rechtsfindung
und auch die kompromissfähigkeit ich
glaube nicht dass deutschland sehr viele
fehler gemacht hat in dieser situation
denn wir werden mit russland als
nachbarn in einer europäischen situation
leben müssen das heißt wir haben an
einer konfrontation
keine interessen das muss man auch mal
ganz klar sehen und das was jetzt
derzeit teilweise in den kommentatoren
ausgesprochen wird würde wenn man das
wirklich umsetzen würde würde uns nahe
an den rand eines krieges bringen das
kann doch keiner ernsthaft wollen wozu
diese verbale rabulistik die nichts
bringt aber heraus habe ich entschieden
sagt dadurch markierte
verhandlungsführer ja da habe ich meine
frage also ich in der tat es gibt hier
niemanden ich kenne niemanden der an
konfrontation interessiert ist und an
verbaler wie auch immer konfrontation
und mit russland im unfrieden leben will
es ist aber eigentlich oben gekehrt
russland sucht die konfrontation und
will hier zeigt er den nachbarn das ist
eigentlich gerne mit den nachbarn im
unfrieden leben möchte
das kann man durchaus auch anders sehen
okay gut dann diskutieren wir das auf
jeden fall in der sendung noch weiter
frau gewünscht ich heute noch auf die
situation in polen kommen was ihre
kirschbaum gerade gesagt hat die kritik
an deutschland im verhältnis gegenüber
russland die wird ja in polen
wahrscheinlich geteilt wie sieht es
eigentlich in polen aus wie sieht polen
auf den ausgang dieses konfliktes das
land grenzt nicht nur direkt an die
ukraine es ist ja zum beispiel auch
durch die
flüchtlingsbewegung und die vielen
flüchtlinge unmittelbar betroffen über
zwei millionen flüchtlinge sind
inzwischen in polen wie sieht man da auf
den aus den ausgang des ukraine
konfliktes was erwartet man da wo liegen
die gefahren auch für polen
russland nach putin oder die die welt
nach diesem weg was wir uns erhoffen ist
in der tat kann zentral thema jetzt hier
weil wir im moment natürlich
alle erst mal drauf voll konzentriert
sind dass es zu einem dritten weltkrieg
kommt und wir sind wie sie auch gesagt
haben unmittelbar in der nähe also die
mit der ukraine ist ja nicht so weit von
dem ort wo ich jetzt mit ihnen spreche
so von warschau und wir haben zwei
millionen flüchtlinge ich hier im land
das land hat voll angepackt also ich
kenne eigentlich im moment jetzt nur
familien die flüchtlinge aufgenommen
haben in ihren häusern oder drehen sich
die gespräche momentan um was ganz
anderes wie gestaltet man den
tagesablauf dieser menschen wie kann man
sie unterstützen psychologisch die kann
man ihr leben weiter unterstützen das
kann man ihn gegeben also darum kreist
die polnische gesellschaft gerade sie
sprachen russland nach putin kurz an in
der frage an meine kollegen
was die russisch-polnischen beziehungen
angeht sie waren eigentlich die meiste
zeit sehr sehr schwierig und sehr
belastet es gab tatsächlich kurz einen
moment 2010 wo man den eindruck gehabt
hat dass es zu einer zarten annäherung
gekommen sei ich spreche davon von dem
treffen von tusk und wladimir putin habe
damals über die verbrechen im
stalinistischen der stalinistischen
verbrechen an an den polnischen
offizieren in katyn gesprochen da gab es
tatsächlich zeichen einer annäherung das
dauerte kurz denn paar tage danach gab
es ja das unglück war die
präsidentenmaschine die in smolensk mit
dem präsidenten der an bord und vielen
vielen hochrangigen politikern und
akteuren der polnischen politischen
szene er verunglückte nach dieser zeit
waren die beziehungen zwischen russland
und polen eigentlich immer schwerer bis
zu eisig könnte man sagen naja und
momentan wird von polen von weiten
teilen auf regierungskreisen
gesagt dass die urängste er nicht nur
wach gerufen wurden jetzt durch diesen
krieg sondern auch bestätigt wurden das
ist innovation in meinem land
was passiert jetzt eigentlich nach dem
ukraine krieg zu sagen sie glauben nicht
dass putin ihnen gewinnt aber wird es
für die demokratien der welt in der
auseinandersetzung mit den autokratien
und da gibt es eine ganze reihe von
mächtigen ländern mit die mächtigsten
länder dieser erde viel ungemütlicher
werden für die demokratischen staaten
des westens ja deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass ukrainisch verliert und
deswegen soll deutschland auch total
interessiert sein dass ukraine wenn du
nicht glaubt deutschland das langsam
gestalt das so spät als nie aber
trotzdem ich war drei wochen in den usa
das sieht man jeden tag viele
berichterstattung über den krieg
wahrscheinlich auch aber wir kommen
sogar nach deutschland und ich höre
berichterstattung über angst über
steigenden
energiepreisen und wir schaffen das
nicht den gas abzudrehen und so ich
würde lieber in eine karte wohnung
sitzen momentan als russische gasse
bezieher nicht ich denke deutschland
könnte das schaffen viel schneller aber
es gibt bedenken ohne ende hier und ich
frage mich bei der krieg ist nur 1000
kilometer von hier entfernt und es ist
wirklich ein ganz wichtiger moment für
die demokratie demokratien und hier hört
man andere sorgen
erstaunlich eigentlich wie ist das in
frankreich das ist ja noch mal 1000
kilometer weiter weg vom krieg ist auch
nicht so von russischem erdgas von
russischen energielieferungen abhängig
die ist das da wie sieht man auf diesen
konflikt und welche gefahren oder
welches möglicherweise mulmige gefühl
hat man dabei also ich glaube da haben
sie recht es gibt eine andere
geografische lage und auch eine andere
geschichte also ich meine das letzte mal
dass wir russland als feind hatten war
gegen also in der zeit von napoleon also
wir wissen einfach nicht wir als volk
was wir haben es vergessen was das
bedeutet russland als als feind zu haben
und deshalb diese ist diese angst die
wir hier fühlen und umso mehr in polen
in der bald kommen also diese
existenzielle angst
vor russland hat man in frankreich nicht
so momentan hinzu kommt dass wir
natürlich auch eine nuklearmacht sind
und da fühlt sich frankreich nicht so
besonders bedroht weil man fühlt sich
einfach stark genug gegen russland
sozusagen ist zwar möglich aber stark
genug makro hat ja eine
mittelstreckenrakete letzte woche testen
lassen das war ja sicherlich kein zufall
aber die force de frappe also die
französische atomstreitmacht ist die
denn tatsächlich stark genug man hat ja
mal gesagt es könnte sogar deutschland
mit schützen genau also ich kann da
diese antwort natürlich nicht mehr
antworten also niemanden wir das gern
die offizielle diskurs ist natürlich wir
sind da wir sind nuklearmacht und das
sind natürlich ein plus in dieser
situation und die die sarah ist wie
frankreich diese dieses krieg erlebt ich
glaube dass ich sie haben auch wahlkampf
momentan und dann kommt immer diese
diese große identitaire frage von
frankreich sind wäre noch eine weltmacht
und die rolle die jetzt mal kroos spielt
im central also immer noch mit max
telefonieren diese ein bisschen dieses
zentrale rolle zu spielen ich spreche
mit jenen und und ich hab auch dieses
offenes kanal mit moskau das gefällt ihm
sehr gut das gefällt auch frankreich ich
meine wir sind da sondern das ist jetzt
die frage welcher interesse hat auch
frankreich sowie sprechen lieber von den
wirtschaftlichen interesse von
deutschland vielleicht darum wie
deutschland nicht so schnell denn gas ab
also den gas abdrehen ich glaube
frankreich hat da keine direkte
wirtschaftliche interesse das ist nicht
frankreich hinterland aber diplomatische
interesse ja gut er glaubt glaubt man
mit putin auf augenhöhe spricht das sagt
er auf jeden fall also das ist die die
offiziellen auch so empfinden also nach
diesem treffen im februar hat makro
gesagt ich habe putin erlebt als eine
einsame mann bunker riese burki hat ja
gesagt also fast wie in seinen eigenen
bunker und heute nachmittag wurde ihnen
noch mal die frage gestellt haben mit
putin telefoniert wie haben sie ihn
erlebt hat er ist er etwas anders in
sein verhalten weil die militärische
lage an sich entwickelt und die antwort
von diesem ballast wir haben davor uns
der gleiche man also putin bleibt wie er
ist und wir sprechen noch mit jedem das
ist jetzt offiziell diskurs also eine
narrativ von der lg er bergmann gerade
als ich die ganz starke vermutung
geäußert
dass ich noch in der frage zu vorstellen
eine ganz starke vermutung geäußert habe
dass die konfrontation gerade von
russland ausgeht haben sie ja gesagt
könnte man auch anders sehen ich war
nichts nur wenn man die bilder der
ukrainischen städte die von der
russischen artillerie platt gemacht
worden sind sieht wie kann man da
glauben dass die konfrontation nicht von
russland oder nicht nur von russland aus
geht
von russland ausgehen es etwas anderes
als das was russland derzeit macht ich
halte es auch nicht für richtig
dass russisches militär in der ukraine
einmarschiert ist das habe ich auch
verschiedenen stellen auch leicht
hochrangig in russland klar gesagt dass
ich das für einen grundsätzlichen fehler
auch eine politische falsch einschätzung
ansehe das hätte russland weder machen
sollen noch machen dürfen darüber muss
man sich völlig im klaren sein das ist
eine aggression die unnötig war und die
letztlich zu einer vernünftigen lösung
kaum einen vernünftigen beitrag
geliefert von daher kann man darüber
eigentlich meines erachtens überhaupt
nicht diskutieren ich finde es wirklich
gut und das muss ich sagen
man kann eigentlich die frankreich nur
dazu beglückwünschen dass der
französische präsident
sagt wir müssen ein kontakt einen
gesprächsfaden mit russland
aufrechterhalten ich unterhalte mich mit
putin ich versuche auch mit ihm zu
versuchen in grimentz zu kommen denn wie
soll es denn anders gehen als dass man
sich an einen gemeinsamen tisch setzt
man kann jetzt noch ein paar wochen hin
und her streiten das kostet sehr viele
opfer das kostet auch sehr viel probleme
in polen wobei es die polen bewundere
mit welcher solidarität sie den
flüchtlingen aus der ukraine gegenüber
treten das ist wirklich bewundernswert
das hätte vor einiger zeit niemand
erwartet das muss man einfach alles
sehen von daher gibt es zu einem
kompromiss und zu einem zusammensetzen
überhaupt keine ernsthafte alternative
und das kann man eigentlich nur
anstreben das heißt man muss alles
unterlassen was dazu führt was auch
verbal dazu führt dass die bereitschaft
zu gesprächen mit dem ziel einer
konsolidierung der lage torpediert
werden und der bergmann nimmt ab mut ihn
denn zb emanuel macau überhaupt ernst
weil sie sagen es gut aus dieser
gesprächsfaden besteht dass dieser kanal
offen ist glauben sie wirklich dass
putin zum beispiel makro ernst nimmt
das glaube ich schon also ich kenne ihn
ja nun einigermaßen persönlich
glaube putin ist jemand der sehr
aufmerksam zuhört der auch sehr gut
gewichten kann
der natürlich auch die interessen seines
landes vertritt das ist ganz klar aber
putin hat zwar einerseits ein sehr viel
sympathien für deutschland da hat ja
auch lange genug in deutschland gelebt
aber er hat glaube ich erhebliche
sympathien auch für frankreich so dass
ich durchaus glaube auch vom typus putin
dass er
ihn nicht mehr ernst nimmt sondern froh
ist dass er in makro einen
gesprächspartner hat der für eine
vermittlung in der lage wäre
wegbereitend zu sein wir wissen aber
jetzt dass ich sympathie für deutschland
war deutschland aus zu nutzen als
nützliche idioten um die eu wohnung zu
teilen dass das putten sympathie für
deutschland wissen sie sehr vorsichtig
mit solchen worten ich wehre mich
dagegen dass wir in einer solchen
sendung von idioten und sonstwas reden
wenn sie sich selbst als solchen
bezeichnen ist dass ihre sagt das und
rief aus den augen verlieren nützliche
idioten war ein begriff im kalten krieg
gut jetzt ist diese diese deutschland
politik gegenüber russland das deutsch
russische verhältnis vor dem ukrainer
krieg war eine völlig andere als jetzt
das ging ja quasi über nacht hat es da
ja eine wendung in der deutschen politik
gegeben gut manchmal sagen besser spät
als nie
jetzt wenn putin mit marko spricht ist
das vielleicht sogar für die westliche
seite ganz gut weil ein gespräch
zwischen beiden und putin kann man sich
ja nie und nimmer mehr vorstellen nach
denen was da war mal ausgetauscht
natürlich ist es gut natürlich ist jeder
das zugpferd das gerhard schöne lag
moskau geflogen ist es auch natürlich
gut aber auch sie gesagt haben dass man
so mit booten an einem tisch sitzen ich
weiß nicht 6 punkten an einem tisch ich
mache ungern vergleiche mit der nazizeit
aber könnte man vorstand mit hitler
hören und tisch zu sitzen kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen wenn putin am tisch
sitzt würde ich mich freuen aber
momentan kann ich mir das nicht
vorstellen dieser mann ist abgetaucht
abgeschirmt dass diese man bereit wäre
einen kompromiss zu finden finde ich
überraschend ja aber mit dem mann
verhandeln natürlich weiß nicht ich habe
keine kristallkugel aber natürlich
wünschen würde ich freue mich dass
versuche gibt aber ich bin nicht so
optimistisch dass das was flüchtet wir
sehen sieht man das in polen glaubt man
dass man auch mit putin jemals wieder
ins gespräch kommen kann sieht man das
pragmatisch oder sieht man sagt er zu
sagen oder sagt man er das was er in der
ukraine
angerichtet hat da ist er quasi jetzt
für polen eine art persona non grata
also unerwünscht wenn wir mit russischen
in der russischen seite verhandeln dann
mit jemandem anderen auch unter der
einschränkung dass es im moment ja
niemanden anders gibt als putin auf der
russischen seite mit dem mann verhandeln
kann
also hier geht man vor allem einem ziel
in generation im kopf hinterher noch
hinterher den krieg so schnell wie
möglich zu beenden
und sie haben das ja schon angesprochen
wir erleben das so nah dran also dieser
schicksale glauben sie mir es gibt
niemanden welche gleichgültig ist und
wenn man sich die politik näher an hoch
die regierung dann wurde zum beispiel
heute
ein einseitiger kohlenstoff was die
russische pole in butter 1 angeht
verhängt der regierungsbeirat gesagt wir
wollen diese bruder nicht mehr das ist
was ich natürlich nicht so viel wie gas
und öl es geht also ungefähr 20%
schätzungsweise was polen oder
verbraucht und es gibt neun manchen
häusern bedrohliche geheizt empfohlen
denn und es wird natürlich auch die
weniger vermögenden leute die eben mit
öl heizen treffen trotzdem hat die
regierung gesagt wir machen das
vielleicht machen wir uns unbeliebt
damit aber wir sehen keinen anderen
ausweg der preis könnte natürlich hoch
seien sie rechnen auch damit dass sie
verklagt werden von von von privaten
firmen der verträge am laufen halten die
jetzt einfach
gestoppt werden müssen trotzdem gehen
sie diesen weg also da an werden
deutliche schritte hier in polen
unternommen
nicht nur symbolische schritte aber auch
schritte die einfach unternommen werden
weil man sich sagt man kann nicht mehr
mit diesem russland heute mit putins
russland weiter reden
es wird gesagt wir haben sehr versucht
und was haben wir davon wenn man
versucht zu reden und dabei so was
herauskommt fehle jetzt in der welt
sehen wo menschen mit einer tasche in
der hand mit einer tüte über die grenze
rennen wir haben so viele ukrainer kiki
stehen vor dem nächst sind in paar
stunden von zu hause weg gerannt nur mit
dem was ihr bei sich hatten die kinder
in die arme behinderung und weggerannt
meine wenn man sich diese bilder heute
anguckt dann
denkt man sich das passt doch alles
überhaupt nicht mehr in unserer zeit was
ist da los fehler ist dass an und sich
mein kriege gab es natürlich in den
letzten jahren auch in anderen orten der
welt aber dieser krieg ist einfach
demografische so nah an uns dass es
sowieso in trebnitz manchmal ist dass
man sich denkt wie kann das sein diese
bilder von panzern die in der nähe von
uns die ganzen tage gezeigt werden in
der kita meiner kinder sind lauter
ukrainische kinder die
die brauchen unterstützung die brauchen
hilfe meine kinder sind vor tagen mit
einer broschüre vom kindergarten
gekommen die sie mir gegeben haben weil
der titel lautet wie spreche ich mit
meinem kind über den krieg also da
kriegt man schon auch gänsehaut hier und
große teile der bevölkerung würde ich
jetzt wagen zu sagen und auch die
opposition großer teil der opposition
unterstützt diese harte sprache
gegenüber putins russland lassen sie
mich noch auf eine fangquote auf einen
aspekt
hinweisen oder besser gesagt sie danach
fragen heute waren istanbul
verhandlungen zwischen der ukraine und
russland da hat ja die ukraine den
vorschlag gemacht
für eine neutralität für ein neutralität
angebot der ukraine wenn das land
sicherheitsgarantien bekäme da wurde
unter anderem auch polen genannt als
eine dieser garantie möchte neben kanada
china zum beispiel auch deutschland noch
einige andere ist das denkbar dass polen
wenn es überhaupt zu einer solchen
sicherheitsgarantie käme da eine
garantie macht für die ukraine wird
es gab heute eine regierungskonferenz
und danach wurde natürlich auch in polen
gefragt man geht sehr vorsichtig erstmal
damit um
dann in frage käme also ich glaube jeder
will jetzt einfach dass dieser krieg
beendet wird und auf der anderen seite
stellen sich alle die eine frage wie
weit kann man vertrauen wie weit kann
man verhandeln um den mann der schon
gehandelt hat und der trotzdem diese
städte jetzt zunichte macht und deswegen
ist also ich habe heute kein weder
dementi noch eine zustimmung
zu diesem thema gehört ich glaube dass
das tier diskutiert herr bergmann es im
moment gibt es im westen ja eine
maximale distanz zu putin
da sie oft in russland unterwegs sind
gute kontakte haben dort ein netzwerk
unterhalten glauben sie dass putin nach
wie vor fest im sattel sitzt auch wenn
die kriegsziele der sich gesteckt hat
und die wohl auch in russland erwartet
worden sind wenn er die möglicherweise
ich jetzt gar nicht mehr erreichen kann
also ich glaube dass im moment keinerlei
probleme hat die zustimmungswerte zu
putin sind jetzt können sie natürlich
sagen das ist natürlich auch durch die
im wesentlichen staatlich gesteuerten
medien
erreicht worden
die zustimmungswerte sind relativ groß
wenn ich mit vielen kollegen auch mit
vielen wissenschaftlern in russland
telefoniere und ich habe wirklich ein
sehr breites netzwerk zu vielen
wissenschaftlichen einrichtungen in
russland gibt es kann niemand der
ernsthaft putin in frage stellt vor
allem weil derzeit auch gar keine
alternative dazu ohne weiteres zu sehen
ist navalny wäre es mit
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht das heißt also
im grunde ist
die zustimmung in der bevölkerung
erstaunlich hoch man kann jetzt darüber
streiten ob das was die putin presse
sagt es 70 prozent sind oder ob es wie
bei uns gesagt wird naja realistisch
betrachtet sind es 55 prozent mag ja
beides richtig sein kann ich auch nicht
bewerten will es auch nicht aber es
zeigt natürlich dass die mehrheit der
bevölkerung den kurs von putin teilt es
gibt auch sehr viele die sogar einen
härteren kurs gegenüber der ukraine in
russland fordern von daher glaube ich
gar nicht selbst wenn es uns gelänge
selbst wenn es dem westen gelänge zu
erreichen dass putin aus welchen gründen
auch immer nicht mehr im amt ist dann
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen wie
eine politik aus sehe die besser werde
für den westen als so die ich will nicht
sagen dass die die putin macht gutes für
den westen aber ich könnte mir keine
politik vorstellen
die wo wir sagen würden ja gott sei dank
das ist ja wesentlich besser als das was
putin gemacht hat das sehe ich nicht
von daher muss man einfach davon
ausgehen dass die bevölkerung in weitem
maße was natürlich auf alte konflikte
zwischen russen und ukrainern auch
zurückzuführen ist gibt es sehr viele
ursachen der für warum die einschätzung
so ist wie sie ist aber die einschätzung
dass putin den richtigen weg geht glaube
ich ist überwiegend und er könnte das
auch in
demokratischen
volksbefragungen attestieren lassen herr
bergmann wenn putin aber so eine
zustimmung in der bevölkerung hat und
einen solchen rückhalt in der
bevölkerung feldes dann der russischen
führung auch leichter auf die
befindlichkeiten der russischen
bevölkerung wenig bis gar keine
rücksicht zu nehmen
ich glaube schon jeder mensch so
dickhäutig das gibt es nicht dass man
auf befindlichkeiten keine rücksicht
nimmt die frage ist inwieweit man sie
umsetzt aber ich glaube schon dass
gerade putin der sich recht sensibel in
diesem punkt ist sehr viel wert legt
dass er eine entsprechende zustimmung in
der bevölkerung hat und wie gesagt ich
kann nur sagen und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass alle
umfrageinstitute egal ob sie levada oder
wen sie nehmen alle attestieren putin
eine zustimmung innerhalb der
bevölkerung
von mehr als 50 prozent in seinem
verhalten gegenüber der ukraine wohl das
nächste g20-gipfeltreffen ist im herbst
in indonesien indonesien ist gastgeber
hat sich jetzt geweigert russland aus
der g20 der wichtigsten
industrienationen
auszuschließen da kann man sich
vorstellen dass putin da aufkreuzt und
bei dem berühmten gruppenfoto irgendwo
in der gegend von makro oder beiden oder
scholz steht also wir sprechen jetzt
heute abend also in die antwort diese
definitiv nein man kann sich nicht
vorstellen und klar zu machen also ich
glaube und das ist auch sehr sehr
deutlich gesagt von von der von der
umgebung von makro also frankreich
verhandelt jetzt gerade nicht mit
russland frankreich redet und das wurde
uns journalisten auch sehr deutlich
heute nachmittag gesagt nach diesem
telefonat zwischen makro und putin makro
stellt einfach forderung da er sagt so
wir wollen jetzt gerade die erste also
absolut erste priorität sehr wichtig die
humanitäre situation in mariupol und
dass die monetäre
ngo s also diese erste hilfe medikamente
wasser lebensmittel dass sie so schnell
wie möglich in aller sicherheit in die
stadt mariupol reinkommen und dass die
bevölkerung auch raus aus dieser stadt
kommen kann egal in welche richtung ist
in drei bedingungen und das war sehr
sehr klar gesagt wir verhandelt da nicht
wir haben gesagt dass sie es wollen und
jetzt warten wir auf die antwort oft
putin deshalb ist auch sehr interessant
zu gucken dass diese
die die rolle dafür frankreich also ist
ein macht sie vermittlung sagt die
ukraine verhandelt in der türkei
momentan mit russland wir aber nicht wir
wiederholen an ver di sieht diddy diddy
die forderungen des alliierten das
waffenstillstand und humanitärer hilfe
sofort für die bevölkerung und dann
gucken sie mal und es hat noch mal einen
schritt nach dem anderen
diese g20
es kann so viel passieren zu wählen da
erstmal kommt noch waren in frankreich
wir gehen davon aus als makro mann
gemacht bleibt aber das kann nicht der
fall sein dann müssen wir mal gucken wie
sich alles entwickelt und dann wie dann
wenn tatsächlich eine andere politische
situation in frankreich kommt wie das
sich organisieren kann in europa und
auch mit der usa noch mal zurück zu usa
nach den äußerungen die weiten jetzt
über putin gibt
ja eher bergmann ja ich wollte noch dazu
eine kurze anmerkung machen ich halte
das für völlig richtig die forderungen
der franzosen zunächst
dafür zu sorgen dass die humanitäre
situation sich in der ukraine
ändert verbessert dass die leute nicht
mehr diese angst haben müssen dass der
krieg erst mal beendet wird das sind die
nahziele danach wird man überlegen
müssen wie welche situation aussieht und
wie eine jetzt über den herbst zu
spekulieren wer mit wem die hand
schüttelte in indonesien ist meines
erachtens eine prophetie und ich habe
juristerei studiert aber nicht
profitieren
es war trotzdem ein hinweis auf eine
situation die man sich im moment kaum
vorstellen kann dass ist passt aber zu
der frage die gehen ja eigentlich
stellen wollte die art die beiden jetzt
putin bezeichnete schlechter
kriegsverbrecher und so weiter hat er ja
eigentlich alle brücken abgebrochen
hinter sich zu putins russland geht die
us-administration davon aus dass es eben
auf lange zeit gar keine kontakte mit
russland mehr gibt nein ich weiß nicht
ich bin nicht in der - traktion ich
glaube die märkte sind flexibel und
breit genug alle alle situationen
antwort weil sie mal den sowie porzellan
zerschlägt geht man ja davon aus das
vorerst machen ja vielleicht doch keine
natürlich hat beiden stärke heute
genommen das kam mit manche länder
besser als hier in deutschland
deutschland hat denn große ding draus
gemacht in polen und usa war das kein
großes ding aber die die linken uns zu
haben dass wörter schneller welt gewählt
und das war nicht teil seiner rede man
es war wirklich nicht dass überbewerten
aber ich meine bewegen hier bei puten
und reden hier über deutschen u-booten
verstehe in deutschland und ich bin sehr
erstaunt ist immer noch so vor mit
putten möchte diese mann hatte
nuklearkrieg jetzt angedroht es ist ein
unding für mich seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg über alles darauf gerichtet so
was zu behindern und dann redet er über
gehe mal davon aus dass vielleicht
einige die vor dem krieg noch putin
verstehen sie sich als solche jetzt
nicht mehr bezeichnet wird ich habe mir
gerade deutschland massiv kritisiert und
nützliche idioten russlands bezeichnung
ein boot aus dem kopf
es geht jetzt nicht um meine
befindlichkeit sondern um die frage wie
deutschland
da stand in dem verhältnis zu russland
anders als die usa sind wir sehr nahe an
russland wir brauchen eigentlich auch
eine gute nachbarschaft mit russland wir
brauchen wirtschaftsbeziehungen und
anders als die usa haben wir auch kaum
energie wir brauchen also rohstoffe
bekommen die ja aus allen
himmelsrichtungen auch aus den usa in
der beziehung hat es die usa einfach
leichter als deutschland die beziehungen
von deutschland nicht so sehr auf
ökonomische sondern auf andere
auf der basis zu stellen natürlich
deutschland hat es auch leichte war die
usa die beteiligung für deutschland mehr
oder weniger bezahlt und die deutschen
müssen gar kein geld für übertreibung
ausgeben und ich haben ausgeglichene
haushalte seit sieben oder acht jahren
dass deutschland unter diesem schutz der
usa ist auch ein portal für deutschland
klar aber die deutschen haben vor allem
nach 20 14 nach dem übernahme von krim
hat die deutsche regierung diese extreme
zwei projekt gemacht und 20 15 aus die
ganze welt auf die syrische flüchtlinge
geguckt haben das ist für mich unfassbar
ja das ist unfassbar und die klebten an
diesen allstream zwei bis zum ende
bei akuten schule gegangen als chance
das ganze in den mund nehmen mit der
pressekonferenz bei beiden das kam in
den usa an etwas so dass ja deutschland
gibt 200 millionen euro pro tag an puten
immer noch 200 millionen euro pro tag
gehen an diese kriegskasse das muss man
manchmal vorstellungen sollen sie
eigentlich google sein war sehen wir ja
was ich darüber vielleicht eine kurze
frage noch zu der zu der reaktion
zum verhalten beiden kommen dass in den
usa selbst gut an beiden war ja vor dem
ukraine krieg sehr unter beschuss
gewesen er sei
zusammen er sei zu wenig entschlossen er
macht politische fehler einen nach dem
anderen donald trump ante portas also
dass der vorgänger sein nachfolger wird
das waren ja alles befürchtungen hat
ihnen das jetzt geholfen in der
akzeptanz und ansehen der amerikaner ich
stell mir nicht so dass beiden total
unter beschuss vom republikaner war
unter beschuss aber der war immer unter
beschuss von dem republikaner
ich finde beides popularität es ist
schon gefestigt und er machte eine sehr
besonnene finde ich gute arbeit der hat
die alle in europa glücklich zusammen
geschweißt vor dem vor den kriegen
ukraine das hat man hier in europa so es
nicht glauben wollen die intelligenz von
der geheimdienste und ich glaube das war
wirklich eine eine sternstunde für die
diplomatie vermeiden und und blinken die
haben die deutschen die haben wirklich
alle alle informationen gegeben und das
stimmte was sie gesagt haben
ich glaube beiden macht schon eine sehr
erfolgreiche arbeit jetzt ein betrag der
umstände dass die wollen keinen größeren
krieg putin droht mit nuklearwaffen und
die amerikaner gucken ganz genau die
marken eigentlich gar nichts zum glück
die machen keine bewegung mit der u boot
und so und beiden bleibt gelassen und er
macht keine irrwitz und so es gibt keine
größere wohnung wie betrachten das ganz
genau und beiden finde ich bleibt
relativ besonnen in diese ganz wichtige
frage die unser aller wirtschaft glauben
sie das makro und joe biden so ein spiel
mit verteilten rollen machen badboy das
wäre im moment jetzt so weiter aus sicht
von wladimir putin und gut gehe
das passt auf jeden fall mit der art und
weise wie viel man politik macht also es
ist wohl möglich dass das so ist und gut
corp
interesse hat ist die frage zu nach
trinkt 2 also da merke ich schon also
die europäer haben sie sich da zusammen
zu halten zusammen diese union ist
plötzlich elena vor allem auge zu sehen
wie ich stehen alle zusammen halten
nicht gerechnet genau das und das ist
glaube ich ein vorteil aber dann meine
frage ist wie lange wir das normal sein
also es gibt schon enormen druck ich
weiß es von frankreich zum beispiel
momentan wegen dieses möglichen geist
gast boykotts das machen wir momentan
nicht weil deutschland dieses gas
braucht also ich glaube schon dass alle
anderen damit einverstanden wäre ich
weiß ungarn wäre da habe ich vielleicht
einverstanden aber das sind kleinen
kleineren städten man könnte alle
zusammenrücken dann
machte sie auch sind auf einen
verbündeten der mine große
schwierigkeiten käme in dem fall
deutschland ja auch etwas rücksicht zu
nehmen
trotzdem zwei fragen wunsch ist ja auch
ein wichtiges thema in polen gewesen das
hat man ja sehr kritisch gesehen sie
haben ja auch vorhin schon gesagt
überhaupt war das verhältnis deutschland
und polen ja in den letzten jahren alles
andere als gut vor allem seitdem die pis
also die partei die
nationalkonservative partei
in warschau an der regierung ist die ja
regelrecht antideutsche die tüten auch
gezeigt hat könnte sein dass der ukraine
kriegt diese beiden länder wieder etwas
näher zusammenbringt weil man sich
natürlich auch fragt gerade bei der
vergangenheit die deutschland und polen
ja auch verbindet dass es doch ziemlich
luxus ist sich da wegen vielleicht sogar
mal petitessen oder lappalien in die
haare zu kriegen gibt es daher auch
einen neuanfang für die deutsch
polnischen beziehungen
sondern eher ein unbehagen an der
deutschen rolle in diesem krieg ich habe
im letzten monat mehrmals über
demonstrationen vor der deutschen
botschaft hier in warschau berichtet
erst ging es
um die geschichte um schrift die letzten
tage war wieder eine demonstration
ausgerufen durch eine gerechte zeitung
in polen hunderte menschen die gegen
deutschland demonstrierten sehr
harte worte in den mund nahmen es wurde
zb gesagt ihr die deutschen jetzt die
heutige generation seit nicht für den
zweiten weltkrieg verantwortlich aber
ihr werdet für diesen weltkrieg waren
folglich verantwortlich sein also
da kriegt man natürlich auch die
gänsehaut wenn man sowas hört also ist
es das ist das eine und in der politik
also heute zum beispiel ist ist kann er
lockt eine ganz interessante entwicklung
bezüglich aufbauen die e mail von ihnen
auch angesprochen hat es ist so dass
polen und ungarn in den letzten jahren
er sich näher kamen
vor ein paar tagen gab es ein interview
des symphonischen präsidenten andreas
der sich geäußert hat dass der verband
eher in diesen zeiten nicht verstehe das
treffen der wischer hat drin da wurde
daher abgesagt und daraufhin wurde
wiederum heute der justizminister in
polen angesprochen und er äußerte sich
dazu ungefähr so er verstehe nicht wieso
man zum prügelknaben gerade gemacht wird
deutschland ist doch an allem schuld
weil sie mich gefragt haben ob ich denke
dass die deutsch polnischen verhältnis
besser werden momentan sieht es danach
leider nichts aus was kommt wissen wir
leider alle nicht nur mal die zeit dass
mal in den letzten jahren wirklich sehr
schlecht und immer schlechter und wir
haben eigentlich herz groß von enten aus
polen meistens über traurige und über
umstimmigkeiten berichtet und zurzeit
sieht es nicht so aus als ob es da viele
gemeinsame punkte giebel zwischen beiden
ländern herr bergmann ganz kurz noch zu
ihrer tätigkeit im deutsch russischen
forum wie sehen sie da eigentlich ihre
zukunft gibt es da noch möglichkeiten
die kontakte mit der die
zivilgesellschaftlichen kontakte zu
russland in nächster zeit wieder
aufzunehmen
das wird in jedem fall notwendig seien
sowohl die wissenschaftlichen kontakte
wie die zivilgesellschaftlichen kontakte
werden in jedem fall notwendig sein denn
wie ich vorhin schon gesagt habe
russland ist nachbar bleibt nachbar und
es hat gar keinen sinn jetzt hier alles
kaputt zu schlagen das hilft niemandem
nutzt auch niemand aber vielleicht wenn
ich im anschluss an das was eben gesagt
wurde noch folgendes bemerken darf man
muss doch einfach sich mal überlegen wie
soll eine ordnung aussehen
bundeskanzler scholz ist bisher in der
sendung praktisch kaum zitiert worden
genauso wenig wie der oppositionsführer
friedrich merz beide haben meines
erachtens gerade zur ukraine krise sehr
bemerkenswerte reden in jüngster zeit im
deutschen bundestag gehalten das heißt
also die deutsche politik positioniert
sich durchaus dazu das ist auch in
europa zur kenntnis genommen worden und
von daher sollte man auch sehen es ist
nicht herr mack allein der hier eine
position gegenüber der ukraine und
gegenüber russland gegenüber polen
vertritt sondern es ist auch eine ganz
erhebliche zustimmung zu diesen
positionen und abstimmung mit dem
deutschen bundeskanzler und dem
oppositionsführer und darüber muss man
darf sich mal gedanken machen wie es
weitergehen kann und weiter gehen nur
weiter gehen kann wenn wir diese einheit
beibehalten dann würde ich das gerne
aufnehmen frau kohl unter kirschbaum was
wenn es um die abstimmung geht jetzt
auch im westen gegenüber russland und
vor allem gegenüber putin wir haben nur
noch anderthalb minuten vielleicht mit
dem kurzen in einer ganz kurzen
stellungnahme was würde was glauben sie
was bringt putin an den
verhandlungstisch was dann auch wirklich
zu effektiven zu erfolgversprechenden
verhandlungen führt also zu
evakuierung der zivilbevölkerung in
mariupol zum beispiel könnte es ich bin
nicht faul
jetzt genau das könnte auch ein vorteil
sein für putin akzeptieren diesen
waffenstillstand für marin voll damit er
die bevölkerung evakuieren lässt dann
könnte er voll militärischer voll
treffen und damit danach seine eigene
armeen um danach an den an der aus front
richtung dornbach es könnte einen
vielleicht eine lösung bringt putin und
wann ich denke hart bleiben und
konsequent bleiben auch eine schwäche
zeigen nicht nicht teilen lassen
gut dann werden wir das wie bei jeder
phoenix runde zum thema ukraine krieg
beenden hier das ist der stand heute
morgen sitzt möglicherweise wieder
anders aber sich bedanken bei allen kohl
bei eric gesprochen hier im studio bei
magdalena quatsch aus warschau
zugeschaltet und wilfried bergmann aus
bonn liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde putins krieg wie muss sich
deutschland schützen es geht um die
ausrüstung der bundeswehr
jetzt folgt phoenix der tag mit hans
werner fittkau
wir bleiben beim thema berichten
ausführlich über die verhandlungen der
ukraine mit russland heute in istanbul
der versuch einer annäherung
eines waffenstillstandes und möglicher
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]